i mean
look in our world all we really have is
credit
i was always bothered by how much value
credit is given
that's the only thing you got i mean if
you're an academic in some sense well it
isn't the only thing you've got but it
feels that way sometimes
but you got the actual we're all going
to be dead soon
you got the joy of having created
yeah the you know the the credit with
yon
uh i've talked to jorgen schmidt hoover
right
the touring award given to uh three
people for deep learning
and you could say that a lot of other
people should be on that list
it's the nobel prize question yeah it's
sad
it's sad and people like talking about
it but i feel like
in the long arc of history the only
person who'll be remembered is einstein
hitler maybe elon musk
and the rest of us are just like well
you know someone asked me about
immortality
once and and i said and i stole this
from somebody else i don't remember who
but it was
you know i asked him what's your great
grandfather's name
any of them of course they don't know
most of us do not know
i mean i'm not entirely sure i know my
grandparents all my grandparents names i
know what i called them
right i don't know in their middle names
for example um
then within living memories i could find
out actually my grandfather didn't know
when he was born
i had no idea how old he was right but
i definitely don't know any of my
great-grandparents are so in some sense
immortality is
doing something preferably positive so
that your great-grandchildren know who
you are
right and that's kind of what you can
hope for which is very depressing in
some ways
uh you can i could turn it into
something uplifting if you need me to
but yeah
can you do the work here yeah it's it's
it's simple right it doesn't matter
i don't have to know what my great
grandfather was to know that i wouldn't
be here without him
yeah and i don't know who my
great-grandchildren are certainly who my
great-great-grandchildren
are and i'll probably never meet them
although i would very much like to
but hopefully i'll set the world in
motion in such a way that their lives
will be better than they would have been
if i hadn't done that well certainly
they wouldn't have existed if i hadn't
done the things that i did
so um i think that's a good positive
thing you live on
through other people are you afraid of
death
i don't know if i'm afraid of death but
i don't like it
[Laughter]
that's another t-shirt
i mean do you ponder it do you think
about the the
the inevitability of oblivion yeah i do
occasionally
um this feels like a very russian
conversation actually this is fair
i will tell you a story a very uh
something that happened to me recently i
um
if you look very carefully you will see
i have a scar yes
um which by the way is an interesting
story of its own about why people have
half of their thyroid taken out some
people get scars and some don't
um but anyway i uh i had half my thyroid
taken out
the way i got there by the way is its
own interesting story but i won't go
into it just suffice it to say i did
what i keep telling people you should
never do which is never go to the doctor
unless you have to
because there's nothing good that's ever
going to come out of a doctor's visit
right so i went to the doctor
to do look at one thing this little bump
i had on the side that i thought my
might be something bad because my mother
made me and i went there and he's like
oh it's nothing
but by the way your thyroid is huge can
you breathe yes i can breathe you sure
because it's pushing on your windpipe
you should be dead
ah right so i ended up going there and
uh
to get my uh to look at my thyroid it
was growing
i was called a goiter um and he said
we're going to take it out at some point
when sometime before you're 85 probably
but if you wait to your 85 that'll be
really bad
because you don't want to have surgery
when you're 85 years old
if you can help it um certainly not the
kind of surgery it takes to take out
your thyroid
so um i went there and uh we decided
i would decide i'd put it off until
december 19th
because my birthday's december 18th and
i want to be able to say i made it to 49
or whatever
so i said i'll wait till after my
birthday in the interview
in the first six months of that uh
nothing changed
apparently in the next three months it
had grown
i hadn't noticed this at all uh i went
and had surgery they took out half of it
the other half is still there and
working fine by the way i don't have to
take
a pill or anything like that it's great
i'm in the
hospital room and um the
doctor comes in i've got these things in
my arm they're gonna they're gonna do
whatever they're talking to me
and the anesthesiologist says huh your
blood pressure's through the roof are
you
do you have high blood pressure i said
no but i'm terrified if that
helps you at all um and the anesthesis
who's the nurse who supports the
anesthesiologist
um i got that right i said oh don't
worry about i've just put some
put some stuff in your iv you're gonna
be feeling pretty good in a couple
minutes and i remember turning
and saying uh well i'm gonna feel pretty
good in a couple minutes
next thing i know there's this guy and
he's moving my bed
and i have this and he's talking to me
and have this distinct impression that
i've met this guy
and i should know what he's talking
about but i kind of like just don't
remember what just happened and i look
up and i see the tiles going by and i'm
like oh it's just like
in the movies where you see the tiles go
by and then
i have this brief thought that i'm in an
infinitely long warehouse
and there's someone um sitting next to
me and i remember thinking oh she's not
talking to me and then i'm back in the
the hospital bed and
in between the time where the tiles were
going by and i got in the hospital bed
something like five hours had passed
apparently it had grown so much that it
was a four and a half hour procedure
instead of an hour long procedure
i lost a neck size and a half
it's pretty big apparently as big as my
heart
why am i telling you this i'm telling
you this because it's a hell of a story
already
tiles going by and me waking up at my
hospital bed
no time passed there was no sensation of
time passing
when i go to sleep and i wake up in the
morning i have this feeling that time
has passed
this feeling that something has
physically changed about me
nothing happened between the time they
put the magic juice in me
and the time that i woke up nothing by
the way my wife was there with me
talking
apparently i was also talking i don't
remember any of this
but luckily i didn't say anything i
wouldn't normally say my memory of it is
i would talk to her
and she would teleport around the room
and then i
accused her of witchcraft and that was
the end of that but she
her point of view is i would start
talking and then i would fall asleep and
then i would wake up and leave off where
i was before i had no notion of any time
passing
i kind of imagine that that's death
yeah is the lack of sensation of time
passing and
on the one hand i am uh
i don't know soothed by the idea that i
won't notice
on the other hand i am very unhappy at
the idea that i won't notice
so i don't know if i'm afraid of death
but i am completely sure that i don't
like it
and that i particularly would prefer to
discover on my own
whether immortality sucks um and be able
to make a decision about it
that's what i would prefer you like uh
have a choice in the matter
i would like to have a choice in the
matter well again on the russian thing i
think uh
the finiteness of it is the thing that
gives it uh a little flavor a little
spice
so well in reinforcement learning we
believe that that's why we have discount
factors otherwise it doesn't matter what
you do
amen well let me one last question
uh sticking on the on the russian theme
you talked about your great grandparents
not remember their their name what do
you think is the
in this kind of uh markov
chain that is life what do you think is
the meaning of it
all what's the meaning of life well
in a world where um eventually you won't
know who your great grand your won't
know your great-grandchildren are
um i am uh reminded of a
of something i heard once that i read i
read once that i
i really like which is it is well worth
remembering
that the entire universe say for one
trifling
exception is composed entirely of others
i think that's the meaning of life
you